dude today I'm doing nothing today I'm
just acting in the piece well not to say
that acting isn't something we act in
our own videos so often that kind of
take it for granted in the sense that
I'm like oh well we have to do a bunch
of other stuff to get a set the camera
get all the props whether you plan out
all the shots to rock
so acting in it is like the last thing
we're thinking about for this one in
particular Nico's like listen if you're
gonna be in this piece you got to focus
hunson on your acting skills and just
let me handle what everything else all
right guys you might recognize this
place from a little Webster as we did
called sync so here's a guy sitting
right here he was like in a bass and he
was like burn that was actually Sam and
then he took a bullet to the head and
died right here and then Charlie our
character and sink he comes in the door
and he opens it up and he's like Carlos
has anyone seen Carlos Ruiz and then we
pretty much did the whole first episode
of sync in this in this building her
hair so it's day two of our Far Cry 3
shoot Sam's been doing a lot of acting
I've been doing a lot of camera pointing
camera pointing I loved decision-making
we've been using this sweet Redrock
micro like focus rig which remote focus
rig which was to be like he's a little
wheel on the side handle for the
Scarlett go focus which what I'm like
getting shots when I call back into the
mat I can pull focus that Anja like move
it off it's super useful at first I kind
of thought the the rig was a little
bulky and messy because there's all
these wires but we've attached it with
Velcro to the camera and
kind of keeps everything packed and you
know keeps all the handles free so it's
really sweet I'm getting antsy I got
your back on set all right I'll see ya
I'm gonna I'm just gonna pass out right
here honestly it's a little uneventful
for me I'm just kind of trying to give
intense looks into the camera and mostly
just equates to me drinking a lot of
water and eating a lot of like swedish
fish
my money dude that's it well right now
viewing the camera I'm running so I can
look at the environment make sure it's
good well and the lights are at a good
level once I do that make it the people
in here start blocking get final
calculation and start wrong Oh finger
acting oh I don't know
just like I think we're gonna put like
green tape around my hand and stuff so
that we have like an actual finger on
the table we'll just kind of like and
pop it out and like erase the rest of my
hand death be not proud and though some
have called the my team and drive not
Shakespeare not think it's children
boating yeah yeah same way but it's
wrong so what kind of spooky dead bars
looks like right now
sounds like Halloween huh yeah WWF red
comm just lets Sam do it it'd mean more
to me if Sam said in my channel Sam will
you say my channel uh it's what's it
like or something I forgot Wow
and this is just mess messed up hey guys
Jess here and I am on 7th quarter
digital and I am playing the Asian hot
waitress
I'm new poisoning someone so it's a lot
like my real life so I'm totally good
just kidding not getting I'm super
excited I am seeing I smell what they're
doing with the set in there it looks
amazing I was like oh I think from the
decor I feel like we're in Thailand so I
brought like every floral printed or
like animal print dressing fine which
were like three I don't know Matt mini
but she's gonna make me look great so
this is my junk rack and I'm labeling it
trying to make it easier for Spencer
since he's taking over a costume
designer for this shoot so he truly is
the MacGyver of corduroy
we got these air cans we're gonna blow
some crap up you might recognize them
from sink but I upgrade them let's see
the bigger explosions you want to see it
tricky how to do that what we're doing
is we're hooking up a harness for
Roberto to do a hand pull we're doing
the table scene where Roberto's on top
of the table or take a line offer Bertos
backside and yank them off the table at
the same time as the tables coming up
all stunts can be dangerous it can be
really safe but then they can also be
very syphilis wood at the same time
because there's just a lot involved you
got to make sure that you're watching
out for everything because you
overlooked one thing then something bad
can happen in 3 2
you pretty psyched for this time yeah
I'm sorry I'm glad he's fully on well
well I'm just sorry I'm just getting a
shower right now of hitting the gun at
Sam we'll be doing right after that is
him doing a stunt where he gets yanked
he goes flying back the Sam just blasted
with a shotgun and we tricked the
audience into thinking it's an imaginary
shotgun but the surprise comes when it
turns out to be a real shotgun and Sam
was just imagining it was an imaginary
shotgun yep after like six hours of
having a fake finger I think I'm finally
circulation probably actually gonna have
to cut it off real at the end of the
night but yeah guess that's part of the
roll so yeah I'm gonna be standing up on
the bar here putting my beretta down
it's and it pulls out a giant shotgun
and blasts me back on these pads yes
holding in here and then once you write
your this fly
boom Co let go this one comes back okay
boom
so it's great my support every every
single part of this I encourage it dance
I think before something split so I
guess I'm just taking screws out yeah
with this pole keep that table like in
this general vicinity that's about ready
to flying I'm hitting it like this is
this funnier sideways means we'll be the
usual champ oh we put more blows so now
I'm ready to go really yeah go yeah it's
going to take this with your right hand
and you're going to stick it on there
and what do you want me to do you're
gonna stick it on there it was you guys
kind of spin your hand or open just like
alright it worked
I put it on backwards I'm sorry
the last shot we're coming the last shot
II go all right guys that's a far cry
behind the scenes we actually got to
meet the team behind this game at e3 and
uh it was actually really cool and it
gave us an idea to go and do something
that's actually a lot more dark a lot
more sinister um we do a lot of funny
stuff uh we do a lot of jokey stuff this
is the first time I think any one of us
is like actually had like blood coming
out of them in a video well usually we
avoid fake blood because it's really
hard to deal with for like continuity
and it's also just sticky and messy
whatever but Sandman it all over himself
so I think this is also the first piece
ever that had drugs in it so yeah unless
you count potions as drugs I think yeah
potions are just wizard drugs so I guess
that makes it okay all right guys hope
you like it follow us on Twitter you can
run into a vision
you